[Music]
in take a joke news submitted by it's my
first time all congrats EXE us bandana
their marriage in her routine oh that's
my very best life experience she's my
favorite oh man well that's art let's
hear what she said like what Eminem raps
about his mom she wanted to suit you
though I know and she lost I think I
know anything that's that should be kind
of like a you have to agree or
understand that if you date a stand-up
comedian nothing is sacred
everything the experience is what the
material is gonna be so be careful or
any artists like if we date Aseema
and they write love songs better believe
it's gonna be about to go well and then
they want credit for I have money for
it's like what the [ __ ] who was married
okay who was it who do you think it was
hmm the comic yeah Sarah Silverman maybe
but she was she married did she yeah she
was married to him oh okay maybe Chelsea
Handler it's not a communion you guys
know how then him then he's suing a poor
person yeah what the hell no they're
definitely poor yeah so her name is
Louise Beaumont 31 years old she's a
British comedian he's probably giving
her a lot of exposure actually Louise
she's gonna blow up at this bro yeah so
cool hair bro well that's her job suck
hmm yeah so the specific routine in
question was a 50-minute performance on
censorship and authoritarianism and so
Louise says that she only referenced her
husband only two minutes out of the
entire set and it was only to tell the
audience how sad she was that her
marriage had broken down but so her
ex-husband is Thomas and so he is suing
her for defamation and breach of privacy
for apparently something that she said
in Santa poutine but neither side will
repeat publicly what she said then it
doesn't matter so we don't know what she
actually said how is it defamation yeah
nobody knows and who
[ __ ] are you like nobody knew who you
were before now they know you [ __ ]
dumbass
you mean defamation in front of like her
audience of 50 people so really he just
wanted to get back at her because he was
mad that she was talking about their her
broken marriage now everybody knows that
you want to get [ __ ] in the ass at one
time and now you're just branded for the
rest of your life yes so he is seeking
about forty two thousand dollars plus
legal costs plus an injunction to
prevent her from publishing statements
about him in the future and so his
lawyers are saying that Louise made
entirely false and very serious and
inflammatory allegations that suggest he
was abusive to her and this lawyer is
also saying that no right to freedom of
expression or artistic license can
extend the to the publication of such
seriously defamatory and false
allegations which against we don't we
don't know what it is so Louis started
to GoFundMe to help her with her legal
cause because she is a struggling
comedian and she has raised almost her
entire goal of about $14,000 she said
this he has a lot more money than me and
he says that I accused him of abusing me
in my show and so he's suing me which in
my opinion my opinion is simply an
attempt to silence me as stand-up
comedians I believe it's the very
definition of our job to talk about our
lives and social issues yeah exactly
yeah and it's and it's people talking
about their experience to so how can you
stop them from whatever they perceive
what happened yeah it's their
perspective do they have different laws
there in the UK about free speech I
heard it skating kind of dangerous out
there yeah people that want to speak
freely so could he could win actually
cuz here I feel like he has no case like
there's no case like she it would cost
him more money to sue her I feel like
maybe people even the United States even
if it's a bad story they want credit for
what you're what you're saying and [ __ ]
you know like on Jake Kane usually if I
say a name it's a different name you
know I mean put that one of my friends
to like they're like oh I'm just didn't
say my name and I was like you know
about you fan about you that's why bro
like you want me to say your name for
this embarrassing [ __ ] story so
usually all the names that I use there
are always different [ __ ] names
because I don't want to help people out
all these like stupid stories but
like attention maybe that's a good thing
here or something yeah I mean it must be
because he'd have to prove how much
money he was losing or how would affect
his a life that she said this like all
this stuff where if it was just in front
of an audience of like 50 people or
whatever if that like that then that's
not very much money that your swing for
it costs way more to sue than it does to
like who sue that an unknown comedian
it's it's a marital dispute kinda yeah
in the personal thing yeah cuz leave
those no lawyers are even saying that
Thomas is citing references that weren't
even directed at him from that family oh
wow my favorite thing is when people say
you're ruining my reputation and they're
a [ __ ] no body yeah what do you have
like you mean like your thirty friends
or whatever like it would have to be
that you're a prominent figure and then
someone says something about you and
it's it ruins business and stuff like
that they might mean reputation in terms
of like our friend circle our family
circle they didn't know this about them
before but thanks to you now they know
this [ __ ] but if you're suing for a
monetary value then that would have to
be worth something but affects your life
in a way that hurts you monetarily yeah
I mean but we're also assuming that the
person that's putting the lawsuit is the
one that's getting like you know
calculating this cost and saying there's
so much it's gonna cost I'm pretty sure
it's the lawyer saying dude we can get
it for this this does this and then the
tab just grew to be this much and he's
like alright I'm down and if it's if
it's not recorded how does he even know
it was and how is it defamation if no
one else gets to hear what was said like
that it means I forget [ __ ] all the time
when I especially if I go to a stand-up
comedy show I'm not gonna remember a
verbatim what the [ __ ] people said like
I'll be like that was funny that guy's
funny that's it I can't remember what
his bit was a little bit he the the
ex-husband doesn't realize he's giving
her a lot of credit cuz he's kind of
fearing that you know she's that good
that she's gonna get big and then people
are gonna hear more she's big now for
sure it's a personal loss big no he's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] up I just you know
or can a comic go though and talk about
people I mean as long as we're not
breaking any laws I think it's artistic
expression to me but also
you loses and she doesn't have that kind
of money like how do you can't get the
money from her she could declare
bankruptcy then you're her you can't get
the money like she does her job is being
a stand-up comic so if you're trying to
garner wages you can't garner a
freelance gig like you can't and I think
they can go as far as and least in the
u.s. as far as it's not defamation like
it as far as it's not a lie I feel like
they could do whatever the [ __ ] they
want you know why cuz when I walk in
there I'm ready to get entertained
yeah it's entertainment yes like it's
exaggerated
it's like some of the act outs might be
constructed in a way where it's a
complete lie or even the way that they
what are those guys call and they like
just yell out [ __ ] again like when they
roast the [ __ ] out of the hecklers yeah
it's like it's so funny but they can't
sue them for defamation I feel like when
you walk in it's like you're walking
into church it's a different culture
it's a different world like it our rules
just don't apply because you're just
saying whatever the [ __ ] you want and
it's like a surreal world right I mean
that's the way I see stand-up comedy or
if I go into an improv show or whatever
it's like be free I think this guy's
just this is his attempt to stay in
contact with his ex-wife I think he's
just oh he left her that she left him
that this is his way of like staying in
her life still somehow yeah sounds like
smells like a [ __ ] a little bit yeah I
got sued once as a struggling comic but
I can't talk about it
but it was a similar like all day
yeah I had no job no nothing like I I
was unemployed at that time like no
wonder you know so much about this you
know you can't go to my wages you can't
I feel like being sued is scary when you
have money yeah but when you don't have
money it's like so what [ __ ] yeah like
what are you gonna take did you take my
sick skittles yeah what the [ __ ] you're
gonna put a lien on my pet the only
sucky thing is if you had to declare
bankruptcy and then later in life you've
made money you have that on your credit
report like it's hard for you to buy a
house or you'd only for ten years who
cares I'll do it all cash just in spite
of mother [ __ ] Sonia don't get
nothing yeah that's right so there was a
writer at that show who went to watching
to review it for a Scottish newspaper
and this is what she says my memory of
it is that she said she'd realized that
she'd been in an oppressive relationship
but it was so minor there was very very
little detail I've seen lots of shows
where people talk about relationships
where they've gone into a lot of detail
about their relationships their marriage
mostly what she was doing was making a
political point it seems extraordinary
that he has taken this view of it tiny
dick mm-hmm the guy's just hurt insecure
wants to hurt her really bad yeah and he
snakes you look like an idiot
that's just so when it's over it's over
just walk away go on like this because
he's mad way man I mean I don't get it
like if you decide to come together cuz
you want to create this relationship you
did there was once a time when you loved
each other or it was it was all good
right why can't you just tap back into
that and go you know what that was a
great experience bye-bye and it's weird
that her thing was about being
oppressive and then he comes in
I bet you this fool just sitting in his
room like yeah yeah cuz then right now I
just seems like you're just trying to
silence her completely but he's like
it's not about silencing the definition
yeah wait
chase you are a nobody but now he's
known all over the world as a business
after like separating from somebody like
I literally just do this thing where in
my mind I go and it is completely gone
that's not added to any X that I've ever
had or any girl that I've dated like
longer than like two three weeks I
usually don't talk to them again just
because what the [ __ ] good point so we
should be friends honestly that's true
however you can have a lot of friends
and if I'm deleted from your life
nothing changes yep so it doesn't matter
but it does affect my future
relationships so I'm not exactly yeah
that's so true
I don't like the friend thing yeah you
see them naked it's like oh so cuz like
you know we're it's been so many years
after high school but if you keep in
contact with certain people and there's
absolutely no love it to me that wasn't
serious yeah it's not it's puppy love or
whatever but if it was a serious
relationship I wanna see you again
I think the only X I've roommate like
that I would consider I'm I'm looking Q
amicable is Isaac said but it's her you
have to do this but it's a gears to cuz
like after the initial breakup it was we
were both young and immature and it just
it was just like this yeah but just to
let you know it's really hard now it's
nice we can actually get along and for
you know for Isaac it's really nice
right
no know what I mean by that is he's
probably still feeling different like
the feelings not mutual
it's platonic for you but it might not
be for him I mean yes totally
alright [ __ ] love it like that was a
few years ago I think he's over here by
now
he's he's good he's dating and stuff
he's heavy